in the george RR martin books that HBO's
Game of Thrones is based on the
character beric Dondarrion has a
relatively small part to play but when
you have an actor is talented as Irish
star Richard dormer you want to showcase
him as much as possible here's a look at
some of dormers previous role to help
you remember just why Barrett from Game
of Thrones looks so familiar
hurricane dormer got his start on the
stage appearing in over two dozen plays
in 2002 a one-man play he wrote and
starred and resulted in dormers big
break with his betrayal of controversial
Irish snooker star Alex Higgins and
hurricane garnering rave reviews over
its three-year run higgins himself was a
fan of the play attending several
performances and striking up a
friendship with dormer following higgins
battle of throat cancer and subsequent
death in 2010 dover revived the play for
a last hurrah at the belfast Opera House
in order to give a final farewell to a
true genius and a legend hidden in 2011
Richard dormer landed a featured role in
a four-part BBC thriller conspiracy
drama hidden starring Philip Glenister
as small-time solicitor Harry Ben when
Venice asked to help track down the
truth about a missing witness he finds
himself well over his head in a deep
conspiracy that may have ties to his own
dark past he enlists the help of dormers
character Frank Hanna a resourceful
ex-con who's out of his depth and finds
himself in more than one sticky
situation along the way
whatever ven is paying him it's
definitely not enough hunted a year
after his appearance in hidden dormer
returned to television when he appeared
in two episodes of the Cinemax BBC
television series hunted joining Game of
Thrones alumni Steven d'Alene and Indira
Varma in the production dormer played
venture capitalist Lewis Conroy who was
present during a murder committed by his
business partner Jack Turner Conroy
later attempts to track down the woman
who witnessed their crime in order to
find out exactly how much she knows Good
Vibrations in 2013
dormer teamed up with yet another game
of Thrones co-star liam Cunningham for a
dramedy based on the life of a Belfast
record store owner Terri Hooley founder
of the Good Vibrations Records store set
during the height of the violent
troubles in the 1970s Good Vibrations
finds hooli opening his Belfast shop on
the most bombed half my
in Europe after hearing some
up-and-coming underground punk bands
Huli embraces the new art form inspiring
the start his own record label
good vibrations gained wide critical
acclaim bringing dormer of Best Actor
nomination at the Irish Film &
Television Awards because it's showing
you know a sense of a sense of people
rising above and against something
that's ultimately dark 71 in 2014
dormer starred in another film about the
troubles when he appeared to the
historical thriller 71 when a unit of
the British Army is deployed to Belfast
they find themselves stationed in a
dangerous neighborhood with Catholics on
one side and Protestants on the other
under attack from both sides they're
forced to withdraw accidentally leaving
one soldier behind dormer plays a
catholic man who helps the soldier
putting his daughter's life in grave
danger
were doomed the dad's army story created
in 1968 by Jimmy Perry and David Croft
the sitcom Dad's Army focused on a
fictional group of British Home Guard
soldiers during World War two the show
became one of the UK's most beloved
comedies running for 80 episodes in
spawning two different movie adaptations
in 2015 the BBC premiered a TV movie
about the making of the series called
were doomed with richard dormer playing
the series co-creator david croft 11
minutes also in 2015 richard dormer
started as a sleazy Hollywood director
in the Polish experimental action movie
11 minutes the film chronicles lives of
a number of Warsaw residents including a
low-level drug runner an elderly artist
a hot dog vendor a skyscraper window
washer a student a team of paramedics
and an actress and her jealous husband
as director Richard Martin holds an
audition for the actress in a hotel room
the rest of the characters go about
their lives but for eleven minutes their
paths all intersect in unexpected and
life-changing ways fortitude 2015
continued to be a busy year for the
actor as that's when dormer got his own
starring television role in the Amazon
original series fortitude playing
Sheriff Dan Anderson the man charge of
protecting the residents of an isolated
town the town of fortitude is
historically peaceful but that all
changes when a local scientist is found
brutally murdered the first violent
crime in the
town's history this would not stop me
never mind a beer
unbeknownst to Anderson one of the
town's residents has placed a call
resulting in the arrival of London
police inspector Eugene Morton who comes
the fortitude to help with the
investigation the show has run for two
seasons thus far with fellow
gameofthrones alumni Michelle Fairley
joining the cast in season two thanks
for watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]
[Applause]
you